the cdc eviction moratorium comes to an
end this
weekend leaving a lot of people here in
las vegas in danger of losing their
homes
but there are options if you're still
unable to make ends meet
sasha loftis spoke with a local expert
who has advice for anyone who's scared
and struggling sasha
denise so many people here in las vegas
don't know what they're going to do is
that eviction moratorium comes to an end
this weekend
i spoke with one man tonight who hit
some tough times but made it to the
other side
he and a local expert i spoke with said
it's important to reach out and ask for
advice when you need it
for eugene pena this last year has been
tough
bills came up things started coming up
you know and it was just one of those
things where
you know it kind of snowballed he was
laid off last march
and described the stress his family felt
when they could no longer
make their mortgage payments there was a
lot of uncertainty
we didn't know what tomorrow was going
to bring we didn't know what the next
few months were going to bring
pena is back on the right track now but
he knows
so many others who fear for the future
as the cdc
eviction moratorium comes to an end
sunday
there are options so you can help with
it there's ways to get out of it pif
lending managing broker andrew levitz
says to reach out to your landlord or
lender
to discuss your options if you're
renting from someone there's a good
chance you have a real person on the
other side of that transaction
just talk to them there's also rental
assistance available
and as long as you apply new nevada
legislation
puts more time on the table as long as
you're trying and making the attempt to
make the payment and whatever it means
possible
governor select did sign a bill to go
ahead and put in the action you can't
get evicted
eugene says no matter your situation
chances are
others have been there before so there's
no shame
in asking for help no person is an
island you know there are resources out
there
leavitt says homeowners also have
options to extend a pause
on payments or apply for a different
type of loan modification
now landlords they have options too they
can apply for a small business loan
or help through that new nevada
legislation that was announced this week
we have more information and more
application information on our website
8newsnow.com reporting live in las vegas
tonight sasha loftis
8 news now